مسلسل النون وما يعلمون من الاعمال
الخليجيه البارزه في هذا الموسم الرمضاني
هو عمل درامي بيعتمد على التشويق والغموض
والانتقام وكيف ان الانسان ياخذ حقه بيده
وين ممكن يوصله هذا التصرف المسلسل من
بطوله الهام الفضاله وشهاب جوهر وعبير
احمد وفاطمه الحوسني وغيرهم طبعا من
الفنانين ومن اخراج حمد سعيد البدري
مستوعبه
ان اللي قاعده قدامك
فرقتيها هي واختها وعمرهم عشر سنين انا
الحمل الكبير
وهذا ريان خاف الله
الجمال
[موسيقى]
من وين نبتدي
انا الحين ما اشوف
اقدر اقول
الفلوس
لكن ما اقدر تغير روحك الغبره انا دست على
مبادئ ومشيت وراك
هذه مو اول مره نشوف الزوجين مع بعض في
اعمال فنيه سبق وقبل عملوا سوا اعمال
عديده منها مثلا امينه حافه حلم امينه
حوبتي وغيرهم وفي النونو ما يعلمون
الثنائي الجميل الهام الفضاله والشهاب
يلعب بدور اخوه الهام بتكون فجر المراه
المتسلطه اللي بتاخد حقها بالانتقام
بلسانها وبيدها لكن شهاب بيكون اللي هو
براك اخوها بيبدو كل جهده على شان كده
يهدي الاوضاع ويصلح اللي يقدر يصلحه
[موسيقى]
انه اللي قاعده قدامك فرقتيها هي واختها
وامرهم عشر سنين انا الحمل الكبير
وهذا ريان خاف الله اروح المخفر اقول
لهم
[موسيقى]
نفسك وتكلمي بدر
وينضم الينا من الكويت الثنائي شهاب جوهر
والهام الفضاله اهلا فيكم معانا منوريننا
اليوم
بعد قلبي منورين بوجودكم وكل عام وانتم
بخير ومبارك عليكم باقي الشهر وما باجي
على العيد تقريبا اقل من تسعه ايام نقول
لكم عيدكم مبارك مقدما
الجميل واول مره
ساره يعطيك العافيه ونقول لكم
مبارك
وعسى الله يعودها علينا بالصحه والعافيه
جميعا وعلى امه امين يا رب
كان عندنا لقاء كان عن الجزء الثاني من
امينه حاف وكان بالضبط قبل سنه من الان
فنحن يعني يبدو هذا موعدنا كل سنه
بالضبط يا حبيبي
كل سنه
نبغى اكثر زيارات اكثر نبغى كذا طيب خليني
ابتدي معاكي الهام هذا العمل يعني بعد
امينه حاف كان صعب انك تطلعي بشيء مختلف
او قلنا لازم الهام تطلع بشيء مختلف
وبالفعل هذا اللي عملتيه مختلف جدا النون
وما يعلمون اذا تقوليلنا عنه
طبعا انا العام وانا قلتها في كل لقاءاتي
معاك ومع وايد مقابلات وحتى كصحافه قلت
امينه 2
انا كنت متوقعه له انه ما يكون نفس نجاح
امينه وين نجح كمشاهده جماهيريه لكن نفس
النجاح اللي اللي حاصل في امينه 1 لا قلت
هذا درس وتعلمت منه لانه استلامي للناس
كان متاخر جدا ما مداني اقدر اقرا عدل
واحط ملاحظاتي عدل وايد تاخروا علي في
الناس فصارت اخطاء حتى يعني انا حتى
انصدمت فيها في ايام التصوير
فمثل ما قلت حق في كل مقاباتي تعلمت من
الدرس وراح تشوفوني السنه الجايه بشكل
جديد وطلعت من العبايه اللي كنت فيها في
الشركه اللي انا اشتغل معاهم في في شمسنا
هذا اللايت كوميدي طلعت منها العبايه مع
طبعا دريم بيكتشر
الانتاج شهاب حبينا نطلع بصوره جديده
تراجدي
تحسين انك قاعد تتابعين المسلسلات
الرمضانيه الثقيله
والخفيفه اللي الناس تحبها بعد الفطور
حبيت اطلع في لون مختلف ولله الحمد نجاح
العمل وخذ المراكز الاولى في الوطن العربي
والخليج وحتى برا
المغتربين في امريكا واستراليا وبولندا
وفرنسا اخذ مشاهده رقم واحد يعني لله
الحمد
رجاحي رجعته ان شاء الله برفعه راس ممتاز
وانا يعني اقدر مره صراحتك الهام في موضوع
الحديث عن امينه حاف وكيف انت تعلمتي من
الخطا حق الجزء الثاني يعني قليل ناس يعني
يقدروا يقولوا هذا الكلام فما بالك بفنانه
يعني من الصف الاول يعني طيب شهاب زي ما
ذكرت يعني الهام انا
قولي
بغيت اقول لك بالعكس انا هذا الشيء هذا
الشيء قلته انا في السوق مو اول مره اقوله
والفنان انا دائما اقول بورصه بورصه سنه
يصعد وسنه ينزل وسنه تضييق الوقت تخليه
يختار ناس عشان يكون متواجد في رمضان فهذا
حال الدنيا مع الفنانين مو عيب ولا هو غلط
نتعلم شهاب زي ما ذكرت الهام يعني المره
هذه الانتاج انتاجك والاشراف العام
لك كيف التجربه كانت
والله للامانه اول شيء طبعا اشكرك على هذا
السؤال وانا للامانه كانت
الامانه ثقيله علي انا بالبدايه كونها
الهام زوجتي كنت وايد استهسل الموضوع ولكن
يوم حطيت على المحك
والهام قالت انا وياك ووقعت وياي بالشركه
هنا صار عندي رده فعل لانه يوم كنت اروح
الشركه اقعد احط الاسامي كنت اتعامل ويا
الهام انها نجمه ما كنت تتعامل وياها انها
زوجه وياي بالبيت
جدا جدي في هذا الموضوع فانا درست الموضوع
بصوره سريعه شفت انه الهام الفتره الاخيره
قدمت لون استمرت عليه تقريبا سنوات مع
اعمالها اللي فاتت يعني اقترحنا وكنا
مصرين انه نطلع بنص تراجيدي بحت ولون
الهام مو طالعه فيه من قبل بعدين هنا
دورها الحلو في انه لها دورين للامانه
يعني فكنا قاعد نحاول بقدر المستطاع ان
اني اطلع الهام خصوصا بعد فشل امينه حاب
يعني حافتوه ان يعني ماخذه نسبه المشاهده
اللي كنا نطمح لها مثل الجزء الاول
والاعمال السابقه والطوفان والى اخره ونفس
الحنين ايضا اللي كان بعد من انتاجي شراكه
احدى الشركات
فقررت اني انا استقل بذاتي واني اشوف نص
يعني نقدر نرتقي فيه ليفل كبير وقوي واطلع
الهام بلون كبير وكان المسؤوليه وهواي
ثقيله علي لانك انت لازم اطلعها بصوره
مشرفه لانها امنت فيني
فالحمد لله يعني كنت قد هالثقه هذه اتوقع
كنت قد
جلسه استنى ترد عليك الهام تقول لك كيف
الموضوع
لانه
على رهان انه يعني هذا كان يعني يعني لازم
الليفل كان يصعد وخصوصا عقب اللي صار لازم
كنا نقدم شيء قوي
وازيد عليه انه شاب من كثر ما حريص علي في
في شركته حاليا اخذ ثلاث نصوص شراها كل نص
اقوى من الثاني قاعد يختار النصوص القويه
مبكر وقاعد يشتريها ويخشها في المكتب عشان
ما يبي اي شيء ثقيله حلو يطوفه ويطلع من
ايده حاليا عندي ثلاث نصوص كل واحد بعد
اقوى من الثاني
صرتوا ثنائي لازم كل عمل حنشوفكم مع بعض
منتج الحين قراره انه راح يشتغل عمل رمضان
عمل رمضان بس اما العمل الموسمي اي عمل
موسمي ممكن اكون انا بروحي
لان رمضان اللي هو
اللي الناس كلها تجتمع تشوف الاعمال واللي
الناس كلها تبي تكون في السباق الرمضاني
ان نجتمع في عمله في عمل رمضان لكن مو شرط
يكون كازواج او كحبيبين عادي طليق عادي
زوج عادي اخوي مثل هني
على كلام الهام بعد يعني وظيف على كلام
الهام باختصار شديد يعني انا تعمدت هذه
النقطه على اساس شنو انه حتى المشاهد ما
يمل انه يشوف اعمالنا كله مع بعض فهذه
خطوه انا خذيتها وكنت عند قراري ومثل ما
صار ايضا في نفس الحنين نفس الحنين انا ما
كنت وياه وجنات وجنات
هذه مساله يعني انا قراءاتي للسوق اكتشفت
ان هذا هو الحاله الصحيه ان الهام ايضا
تشتغل وانا اشتغل ولكن قاعد نرتب اوراقنا
صوره حلوه والدليل والدليل على ذلك نفس
الحنين كان من انتاجي انا ما كنت متواجد
فيك ممثل ولكن كمنتج موجود
اخوها مو دور زوج او
حبيبك
بس ايه ما شاء الله ايوه صح في هذا
النموذج كمان بس انه تحيه لهم طبعا هالسنه
بعد مو زوجها ايه بس انا كنت يعني ما شاء
الله انتوا يعني خلاص انتاج داخلين مع بعض
واعمل نصوص مستقبليه وما الى ذلك قبل فتره
كان طلع يعني خبر انكم انتم انفصلتوا بس
ما شاء الله يعني شكلها الامور جميله
بينكم وان شاء الله رمضان الجايه شايفينكم
بعض والكلام ده كله
هذا اول مره اسمع منك
قبل شهور كذا قبل شهور
بالشهور غاب شويه شهاب عن سنابك يمكن
فالناس على طول
تكون متشبعه منه بشكل دائم فالهام ايضا
لها استقلاليتها انا الاستقلال زين الشغل
ذلحين مع الحليب
اذا اجتمعنا طالعين ويا بعض
الظروف هي اللي تخلينا
النوع اللي نتعمد انه يلا تعالي
يعني ما تبغى تتعاملوا مع بعض انكم كانكم
من الكابلز السوشيال ميديا
لا لا احنا مو ساره عشان ابسط عليك اول
ايام يوم كنا نصور 24 ساعه
المطعم
لابوتيكات شهر عسل الحين خلاص صار الوضع
طبيعي متى ما طلعنا طلعه حلوه صورنا
حياتنا هذا اوكي طيب وصلت هذه الفكره بدي
اسالكم كذا شويه اسئله بس على المواضيع هل
عندكم قضايا مرفوعه عليكم انتم رافعين
قضايا على احد
انت رافعه قضيه على مين
موجوده نفسها وفي المحاميه هي البستلمه
القضايا مالتنا اللي يعني في قانون ياخذ
مجرى
يعني
اخر قضيه الشكوى اللي مقدمينه اخر قضيه
كانت
تحريض الصحافه
اذكر الدوله تحريض صحافه خليجيه علي انا
الصحفي والشخص اللي عليه
الشخصة المعنيه قصدي القضيه
لانه طيب
يقال كمان وحده من الاتهامات اللي عليكم
بده يقال انكم انتم سبب في قطع رزق فنانه
وكثير بينكتب لكم هذه التعليق على
السوشيال ميديا
اعوذ بالله اعوذ بالله اول شيء قطع
الاعناق ولا قطع الارزاق وهذا كلش مو
مبدئي ولا من اخلاقي هذه شغله شغله ثانيه
بقول لك فيها ساره على هالسالفه انا دايما
اقول لهم هالموضوع لما نشوف بعض المقاطع
ظلموني او اقطعوا رزقي سالفه الرزق هذه من
الله لا بيجي ولا بيدك واللي بيظلم يظلم
نفسه من ايده هذي شغله شغله ثانيه انا لو
بطلب اقطع الرز انا ترجيت عبد الوهاب
العيسى وهو حي يرزق موجود دشيت مكتبه في
بوتيكات وترجيته رجوى انه يدخلها بوتيكات
وكنت ماسكه تلفوني واغلى سنابها واقول له
اشوف شوفي شو مسرحيتها شوف العرض تكفى
خلاص خلاص ان شاء الله ان شاء الله ما دار
يومين الا وقعوها بوتيكات ابسط قطعه رزق
يا ساره انا من التوب سيلفريتيفي بوتيكات
واول وحده وقعت عقد بوتيكات ولذي كلمه
مسموعه لله الحمد
[موسيقى]
الايام الفضيله ما بحلف فيها كذب والله
العظيم ان بيني وبيني يعني في نفسي
وبيسمعوني اقول حتى ما صار في خط رجعه
ما اتركوا اثر جميل ان الواحد يرد وفيه خط
رجعه يعني
ورا طقه هذي خلاص يعني ذاك اليوم اسولف حق
شهاب اقول له يمكن الغلطه الاولى اعديها
الثانيه اعديها
واسامح يصير بين الاهل وبين الحبايب ماكو
مشكله بس لكن في حدود وفي خط رجعه تصير
لكن الموضوع صار اوفر انه خلاص
خلو ما عندك خط الرجعه مستحيل قام تتخوفين
من عندها الناس يعني عند الله بيننا وبين
قطع الارزاق
يعني لو بسويها ابسطها لو بسويها كان
سويتها
بعدين منو احنا امام رب العالمين وصل
اي وصلت
خليني اقول لك شغله خلني اقول لك بقول لك
شغله في فنانه مشهوره من الفنانات
الكويتيه مرت في نفس الموقف ومعروفه يمكن
تعرفينها الوجه لها تحيه كل ادب واخلاق
قبل كم سنه صار لها نفس الموقف وهذه هي
لحد الان حالها من حالها ما طلعت هذه
الفنانه قالت انا ظلمت انا انطقيت انا ليش
ما تكلمت عرفت قدر مسؤوليتها وقدر الغلطه
اللي هي سوتها وقاعده الحين ساكته ولا
تفتح باب ولا سمعنا طقوها ولا سمعنا قالوا
رزقها تحملت غلطتها وقاعد تحاول تصحح وصلت
وصلت
واقطع رزقك من دوله وصلت وجهه نظركم وطبعا
يعني الناس يعني عارفين انتم بتتكلموا عن
مين طبعا
وبامكانها هي لها حق الرد كمان
يعني ممكن هي كمان يعني ترفع قضيه او ما
الى ذلك بس انه على العموم شكرا لكم
منوريننا ورمضان كريم عليكم ومكسرين
الدنيا بالمسلسل كان معنا من الكويت يا
حبيبتي الله يسلمك
شكرا لكم
[موسيقى]